so a fair fight can be fun to watch but
sometimes you just want to watch a
competitor get completely destroyed so
today we're going to compare a fifty
dollar camcorder to a $50,000 cinema
camera not only will the difference is
in similarities between surprising but
they'll also help you understand what
makes a camera good this is a sony
handycam HD STX 405 I got the Craigslist
for fifty bucks
this guy isn't the red epic dragon
Cinema Camera it's been used in films
like The Hobbit the Martian Prometheus a
whole bunch of other films the brain
alone on this camera is around thirty
thousand dollars we upgraded to be
scarlet the epic we upgraded to the epic
dragon basically over three years ten
thousand dollars every year to get to
this camera it's not exact but for the
sake of the title of this video 50
dollars versus fifty thousand dollars
sounded a lot better than fifty dollars
versus forty-seven thousand two hundred
and twenty nine dollars first comparison
are going to start with this resolution
so resolution is where the two cameras
show their biggest differences at first
we put the camera side-by-side with the
same field of view at a glance they
generally look the same and I think it's
a testament to modern camera technology
that they do but once you start zooming
in we'll start to get a different
picture here the camcorder is actually
very blurry and somewhat noisy compared
to the red also all the tiny fine
details in the red really pops for
example the great on the air-conditioner
you can see the individual bars versus
the blurriness and camcorder or in the
distance a security camera is clearly a
security camera on the red but a white
blob on the camcorder
also the bricks are not interesting
things that they've notice because in
the camcorder all that fine detail of
the individual bricks gets blurred into
one smooth flat color because of the
compression and finally cameras tend to
encode different resolutions for color
versus black and whites basically what
we refer to as luma and here looking at
the two images side-by-side we can see
how the red is getting much better color
resolution on the blue gutters and red
beams of the train station building
versus the camcorder where those just
get blended into the same color that
real wasabi it must be so I love wasabi
peas and stuff and sorry I saw these or
what some of your rice crackers
and I had one today and I had the most
violent reaction to a temperament but
twice you just like you like get
careless and you can't pray for your
head
do you gotta chew it up eat it I'll do -
you want to try - OH - right - all right
ready move you suffocate this remember
to keep breathing
mmm it hit me read the supplement if you
all did you ready free fight one go yeah
why why didn't I do this maybe you've
been recording with the camera and you
couldn't really see the screen because
it's too bright outside and you dialed
in the wrong exposure settings and
everything's really overexposed so we
want to do a side-by-side test the two
cameras and see which ones could handle
overexposure than most gracefully so
starting off your camcorder overexposed
by a couple stops we can see that
everything's going to a very hot white
versus the red everything is relatively
the same brightness a similar exposure
but it's handling those hot whites a
little bit differently and side by side
you can start to really see the
differences for example on Nick's
forehead or on the light on the camera
especially on the roof now we try to
correct these two images we can really
see the difference between two cameras
the red actually looks like a normal
camera with correct exposure when we
bring it down but the other camera the
camcorder you can see that the white
highlights on Nick's forehead for
example or on the cameras little mounted
light they don't gain any color back his
forehead stays white and just becomes a
grey basically as we pull it back down
verses on the cinema camera there's
still detail there and there's still
color data there so overall the cinema
camera is handling the overexposure much
more gracefully as of course is to be
expected but what it really shows you is
that the camera is much more forgiving
so if you make a mistake when you're
recording something you're not going to
get fired so just like with overexposure
sometimes we have accidents and we make
our footage too dark so how do these two
cameras hold up when we accidentally
under expose our footage let's take a
look at a glance here's the camcorder
and then here is the cinema cameras they
generally look the same
same kind of colors same kind of
brightness I tried to dial them in to be
about equal by eye but once we start
brightening up footage to recover it the
differences will start to become
apparent so for example here at the
camcorder now we can see that's a lot
softer than the red and the noise in the
grain is a lot larger the cinema camera
isn't really a low-light camera either
but at the same time we can see how the
image on the cinema camera is holding up
now here if we take a look at the dark
shadows in the leg we can really see
some examples of how the codecs or the
compression being used on the camcorder
impacting the footage we can see these
large green blocks which are a byproduct
of h.264 h.264 is trying to minimize the
amount of detail it has to encode
because more detail means more data
so taking spots of the image where there
is in detail and trying to dis advert us
out to basic flat colors so on Nick's
leg we're getting large blocks of green
whereas in the cinema camera with a much
better codec it's still trying to retain
a bunch of information and data which
generally is leading to finer bits of
noise and grain here and that's just
drew Christian is the do we have last
name on this guy Lehman something caught
my eye from across this video actually
no we didn't catch Maya come across this
video caught my eye from our Instagram
because I didn't even see it come in for
that that's pretty cool
drew Lehman sent us the part inspired by
our videos there's one in particular
that was really really really cool it's
this one right here it's a Peter 42
designed to follow us on Instagram we
have seen this and what is beautiful I
think you for forty second iteration and
a long lineage of Peters but I feel like
this weird rendition though it looks
like a lot larger than life this isn't
even further than you've ever done we've
got the cyborg arm we do have bio
implants we have a ragged tank top long
we handle in a tuft of hair being swept
away by the world honestly this really
cool compositional stuff going on but
any interest in maybe a shirt like this
let us know if you voiced your support
you might turn this into a shirt we
might turn this dream into a reality
Volk identity
there's a lot of white space in this
area here if you have any art of your
own feel free to just dig but it's
already taken maybe a send it to us
physically in the mail I don't really
need to do I really have to tell you
where I addressed it the next test we're
going to do is that of color resolution
we're often referred to as color depth
for the camcorder it's an 8 bit camera
so 8-bit footage means you have 256
values describe the red channel your
green channel to your blue channel now
the cinema camera is 16 meaning as
65,000 individual values for the red
channel the green Channel and the blue
channel so we're going to do a stress
test here for the cameras first I'm
going to show you side by side the
camcorder and the cinema camera just
looking at the blue sky and honestly
side by side without any change to the
color they kind of look the same not bad
to the camcorder but now we're going to
add some contrast we're going to make
that sky as contrasting as possible to
pull out as much color detail in the
middle as possible this is where things
get interesting
so I also pull up the contrast in the
sky on the camcorder we can start to see
is that there's not a whole lot of
colors to work with and in fact we're
dealing with a lot of the noise well you
basically you step from a white to a
cyan to a medium blue to a dark blue a
very dark blue and in the black now when
we start to add contrast cinema camera
with its 65,000 values of color for red
green blue suddenly the sky looks much
much nicer and we don't see any stepping
see a lot of subtle gradients a lot of
detail is very much being preserved by
the cinema panel so you may have heard
the term dynamic range before when
talking about cameras what that means is
it's the total range of brightness that
a camera can take in on a sensor from
getting detail in the darks to not
flowing out and clipping the highlights
so what we are going to test here is the
dynamic range difference between the
camcorder and the cinema camera in the
way we're going to do it is by filming
in a darkened room and then turning on a
bright light so here we have the
camcorder with a light turning on and in
the moment it turns out to see Nick skin
blowing out on the cinema camera and the
light turns on it skin kind of blows up
we see a lot more detail side by side
you can really start to see the
difference also note how the color is
handled on the border between the shadow
and the blown out highlights on the
camcorder you see detail in Nick's
mustache you can see detail on how the
highlight rolls off your nose
and that's another important aspect of
these cameras is how they handle that
roll off to a highlight and your bright
highlights you still want a touch of
color in them so on the bright side of
Nick's face on the cinema camera you can
see detail we can still see tonality
it's very very close to white but it's
not maxed out the sensor isn't screaming
I'm at a hundred percent whereas in the
camcorder definitely maxed out there's
nothing you could do to fix that you're
doing it you're doing your double drop
it at a single one yet give me that
Chris you can't be pressuring me if he
hasn't done it you guys I hate your
solitude it's fine for mommy somehow I
know I'll be three your left you have to
have a won games of the real tanks green
ones with their extra stick wasabi on
them oh oh okay oh you feel it a villain
top my brain feel it right here and then
it back right between your eyes
literally right in my brain I don't get
real notable you get a close-up of that
that the dank nug that's good it takes a
minute
yeah most kind already this is actually
one of the biggest differences between
high-end cameras and low-end cameras the
camcorder is according to h.264 that's a
codec that's used to basically take
video data and compress it so it doesn't
take up a ton of data on your computer
so for example all the videos you're
watching in youtube this video right now
is encoded as h.264 and what that's
doing is it's trying to minimize the
amount of data it takes to describe a
frame of the video for example as are
sitting here this wall isn't changing so
h.264 isn't spitting out new data for
this wall for every single frame of this
video it's basically spitting out the
data once and then telling your computer
hey this wall stays the same for the
next 10 seconds I don't need to read
ascribe to you for every single frame
and that saves data now the downside of
that is if I were to start changing
things every single frame h.264 codec is
somebody struggling to keep up because
every single frame is different so I
haven't really ever seen anybody try
this test before what I did is I took
each camera I raise the shutter speed so
there is no motion blur and I shook the
camera as fast and as hard as I could
so here we are looking at a highly
detailed wall and without much motion if
we just look at this grass and this wood
here on the camcorder we can actually
see there's a fair amount of detail and
as we saw on the resolution test earlier
the the cinema cameras certainly has
more resolution but you can see the wood
grain we can see the individual blades
of graphs so all in all not that bad of
an image now as we start moving this
camera we look back at the same spot
suddenly we see compression rearing its
ugly head all that fine detail in the
wood grain all that fine detail in the
grass it's suddenly getting blurry that
wood grain is basically becoming one
flat orange color the rashes becoming
kind of a blurry mess of green and a lot
of those fine details are being lost
because to describe all the details for
that one-frame fresh require more data
for that frame in the camcorder in
process and also we can start to see a
bunch of compression artifacts or
waffles as Nick likes to call them bunch
of little squares all over the place
waffle town population 30 now going to
do the same with the red so here we are
with minimal motions look at this wall
we can see plenty of wood grain we see
all the grass just fine detail the
individual hairs and the little fuzzy
on the grass now with a bunch of motion
we come back to the same spot and it
looks almost identical we still see all
the wood grain so see all the graphs we
still see the individual hairs with seed
potholes so this cam core is the mayor
of waffle town whereas the red just it's
more of a pancake I guess no Awful's in
sight anywhere hopping kids like me go
thank you a time they're really cool at
a time you know it have to go for two
that would be tank one hates bad no come
on how does it really disappointing
reaction I nearly died the chest I
should call color accuracy we're going
to throw a bunch of different colored
lights at a subject we're going to see
which camera can handle all these crazy
wonky color lights so here we have the
camcorder footage straight from camera
we have a red light of the left blue
light on the side and actually kind of a
greenish light from the front and then
we have the cinema camera footage and at
a glance
once again they actually look pretty
similar just right out of camera there's
actually a testament to all the
engineering bullion to that camcorder
it's being precisely engineered to give
you that one image as best as possible
two cameras side by side without any
manipulation generally look pretty
decent orange to red light is a little
bit blown out on the camcorder versus a
cinema camera but beyond that it look
pretty good but once we start color
grading this we begin to see some issues
we can see on the bright red side of
Sam's face a lot of detail and tonality
is actually being lost the border
between his beard and his skin is
looking really wonky and then that blue
side we're having issues the highlights
and right we're having issues with how
those highlights transition into the
other colors the border between the blue
highlights and the orange is really
weird looking and kind of wonky and has
some weird dark lines compared to the
Cinema Camera
and this is an example of once we start
combining a bunch of these weird colors
we start to stress out what this
camcorder can process hopefully what
we've done here is help illuminate what
you should look for in a camera and
whether you're shopping for a 50 dollar
camera a 100 dollar camera a thousand
dollar camera ten thousand dollar camera
now you know a little bit of what you
should look for in a camera and what
helps it get a good image also I want to
give the camcorder some credit a little
Sony Handycam it actually held up really
well when just side-by-side without any
processing it actually kind of stood up
to the red it's still a little beast
it's trucking along you went back in
time 20 years and drop that on from
these desk you blow their minds thanks
for watching and if you want to learn
more about cameras Tech and all that
kind of stuff we've made a little
playlist here of all the other kind of
educational videos we've done you know
how to tell a story how to film an
action theme how to make guns look real
for an action scene and a whole bunch of
other crazy stuff I hope you enjoy and I
hope this helps you capture better
images